Hi.
My name is Moin Nadeem,
and I'm currently
a junior in electrical
engineering and computer
science.
My work broadly goes over
automated fake news detection,
more, specifically automated
factory information.
Given some claim
like, did Barack Obama
win the 2016
election, I provided
probability of how much this
claim is true or how much of it
may be false.
If you think about
how you may do this,
you would think, OK,
given some claim,
which evidences do I have to
support or refute this claim?
So I've created a search engine
that given some query retrieves
all possible evidences
and retrieves how
much these evidences agree
or disagree with this claim.
Now, once you have
a list of evidences
that support or
refute this claim
and you know how much
they support or refute it,
you may want to also figure out
how credible is each speaker
because, for example,
one adversary may
want to flood the internet with
a few dozen small websites.
And that doesn't mean
that this is as credible
as say, for example, an
established journalism
like the New York Times.
Because of this, we finally
take these evidences,
and we know how much
they agree and disagree.
And we weight these
by who's speaking
and how much credibility
do they have.
Finally, we can return
this weighted sum
over who's speaking, how
much credibility they have,
and what are they saying.
More specifically, I'm
working on the first pipeline,
which is evidence selection.
Given some query, I return
a list of sorted documents
representing how
relevant each claim is
and what number the document
is in that position.
One way to think about
this is I'm basically
building Google search.
You type in some query, and you
get a list of sorted documents.
Google Search has a 56%
chance of showing you
what you want to see as a
first result on the list.
For the search
engine I've built,
I have a 79% chance
of showing you
the result you want to see as
a first result on the list.
This means that we
have more information
to [INAUDIBLE] more accurate
fake news assessment.
Check out our demo
on factor.app,
and I'm happy to
discuss this more.
Thank you.